okay so good morning we are continuing
the Hebrew Bible
today um last class we talked about King
David of Israel and how he created the
Bible the the project of the Bible in
order to create legitimacy and Authority
okay we're continuing along this theme
today so let's go over the
chronology of the Bible okay
um so in the
beginning there was God okay in the
Bible his name is
Yahweh and he created the
world and then he created Adam and
Eve in the Garden of
Eden and people who took the Bible
literally believe this was about 4,000
BC
okay as we know Adam and Eve because
they
disobeyed God they were banished from
the Garden of Eden and then they had two
sons K and Abel and then uh their family
start to populate the Earth but then
humans start to misbehave we went to war
we were
greedy and so God decid decided to
destroy the world something called The
Great Flood and this is a story of
Noah's
Arc remember
Noah uh was beloved by God so God told
him to build a great ship and then he
will be able to live okay um after
Noah's Ark um came along a man named
Abraham and this was about 2,000 BC
Abraham was born in the city of of er in
Mesopotamia and he was beloved by God
because he was a righteous and decent
man and God made a covenant with him
Covenant and a covenant is a contract
it's a promise and the contract is this
if you Abraham swear allegiance to me
Yahweh I will make you and your
descendants founders of a great nation
called Israel that will stretch from the
Nile to the frates that's a promised
land and return uh as a mark of this
Covenant Abraham and his ancestors will
engage in circumcision okay basically
the foreskin of their penis will be
surgically surgically removed at Birth
okay so that's the
Covenant Abraham had a son named Isaac
and Isaac had a son named
Jacob okay um Jacob is the younger son
of um Isaac so asau should have inherit
the birthright and the blessing from his
father Isaac but Jacob played a trick on
ASA and stole the birthright ASA was
very angry so Jacob had to run away and
live with a relative for um a couple of
decades and while there he married two
sisters
named Leah and
Rachel and then together they had 12
sons and these became the 12 sons became
the 12 founders of the 12 tribes of
Israel Jacob will be renamed by God as
Israel so Jacob really is the founder of
the nation of
Israel Jacob Jacob's youngest son is
named Joseph and he is beloved by
um Jacob so much that his brothers
became jealous of him and sld him into
slavery in
Egypt Joseph was also beloved by God and
he had a special gift of reading dreams
and he became a special advisor to the
Pharaoh and he became very wealthy
meanwhile back in the land of Israel
Jacob and his sons their family are
facing this massive famine so Jo Joseph
comes and rescues them and the entire
nation of Israel moves down to
Egypt okay where they become very
wealthy and prosperous and because they
have many
children eventually after a couple
decades they become a threat to the
establishment so the new theough who has
no memory of the contributions of Joseph
enslave the
Israelites and he wants them to die so
he basically forbids them to have uh
sons and he um um basically tries to
sanction the Israelites as much as
possible eventually a man named
Moses is Born Into the Israelites in
Egypt and because he's a boy he has to
be killed so his mother puts him in a
basket and then this basket drifts down
the Nile and into the hands of Egyptian
princess so Moses grows up to become um
Egyptian prince but eventually God
informs them of who he really is and
he's the prophet um who will deliver the
Israelites back into the promised
land the Pharaoh refuses to let the
Israelites go there's a major contest
dual between Moses and the Pharaoh and
then God sends down like 10 plagues okay
10 plagues
to force the pharaoh to release the
Israelites Moses is taking the is the
Israelites into the promised land and
then Pharaoh CH has a change of heart
and he wants to destroy the Israelites
before they can escape so the Pharaoh
chases them Moses causes the sea to part
they they cross the valley and when
pharaoh and his army are about to enter
the sea the sea closes in on them and D
them
okay and then when Moses and the
Israelites are in the desert Moses
ascends the mountain to receive the law
of God and this is what we call the Ten
Commandments but while Moses is
away the
Israelites created an idol to celebrate
Yahweh and Yahweh hates this because
Yahweh does not want to be represented
on Earth so Yahweh um sends him to a
long Exile in the desert and he tells
Moses you will deliver the people from
Egypt and that is your mission but you
will not enter the promised land you can
see the promised land but you will not
enter the promised land so the mission
goes to Joshua who is Moses deciple and
Joshua and the Israelites start a
massive military campaign in into the
land of canine which is a promised land
and over the span of years they
basically Massacre the people and they
create the nation of
Israel and then we enter the period
called the judges and these are 12
individuals who become the tribal
leaders of Israel and Israel at this
time is at war with all the neighbors
the moabites the the
Philistines the
Canaanites um and this perod last for a
long time until the Israelites pick a
king named Saul to lead them okay King
Saul and then as we know from King Saul
will come David who will use up the
throne from Saul and be the great king
of Israel that we that we remember today
okay and David is considered the real
founder of the state of Israel as well
as the Jewish faith so that's the
chronology
of the Bible now because the Bible is
written almost like a historical
document for most of in human
history people believe this to be
literally true okay but in the past 400
years 300 years there are many
archaeologists who have tried to
prove the events in the Bible for
example Noah's Ark If there really was a
flood well there would be a a geological
record there would be a ship okay there
would be a memory of this but there was
never but but we have never been able to
found any concrete evidence to support
North Art okay how about the garden of
of Eden well if the Garden of Eden
really existed well we could also find
it and we've never been able to find it
all right how about Abraham Isaac and
Jacob again no evidence that any of
these IND indviduals ever
existed how about
Moses well we would think if Moses
really did exist there would be some
records of him in the Egyptian history
right I mean 10 plagues is a travesty
and a disaster on the Egyptian people no
record of that uh The Parting of the sea
no record of that uh the
judges uh Joshua nothing okay it's only
it is only until we get to David when we
begin to see historical records and
proof that David actually existed but
before that nothing in the
Bible um has proven to be um
historical okay and so this is very
confusing so what I will show you today
is If you see the Bible as a historical
record you will only get confused if you
see this as as a chronology
this makes no
sense if you see this as a work of
fiction like a lot of people do this
doesn't make much sense either okay
because when you read the Bible these
events aren't actually interconnected
with each other David has no memory of
Moses for example that's weird Moses has
no memory of Abraham okay so these
stories are not
interconnected so if this is not a
historical record if this is not a work
of pure
fiction what is this thing okay what I
will show you today is this is not a
chronology this is a cosmology
cosmology
okay it remember last class we talked
about why things are written down in the
ancient past and as I said King sponsor
writing projects for three major reasons
the first reason is to create legitimacy
and
Authority the second reason is to create
a national identity cohesion among the
people the third reason is the idea of
differentiation to tell people who they
are not we're Israelites we're not
Egyptians we're not Canaanites we're not
Philistines okay so these are the three
major reasons why
Kings
sponsor writing
projects and for the Israelites and
David these
three um imperatives are particular
Salient okay they're really necessary
right so let me explain why that's the
case so
legitimacy
remember David usurped the throne from
Saul Saul came from a noble family and
he was elected by The
Chieftains to be their
King and then David launched a rebellion
and eventually user the throne so David
has a major legitimacy problem so how he
solves the problem as we discussed last
class is the Bible presents him as a
poet King okay this is very important
concept poet King there have been
Warrior Kings right Kings who go to war
and they win legitimacy by defeating all
their enemies there have been priest
Kings Kings who are head of a major
religion but David is the first poet
King okay he writes poetry he sings
songs he's a sensitive Soul that's
that's what explains his affair with
basiba and that's that and that tells us
he could never have possibly been
ambitious and want to kill Saul okay
he's the first poet King so why is he
king of Israel because guess what
guys God is the poet
God okay poet God Yahweh is the poet
God so this is a radical conception of
divinity in the ancient
world Gods previously have been priests
or Warriors and this is the first time
in human history where God Yahweh is
presented as a poet God when you read
the Bible it's very interesting how he
creates the world he speaks and things
are
created okay he says let there be light
Let There Be Heaven and
Earth he speaks and when he speaks a new
world is created and he and then he
looks at at this word and
says and this is good okay so he's like
a writer who speaks words and who edits
his words in order to create something
much more beautiful he's a poet and as a
poet he's very
sensitive okay which means he creates
Adam and Eve because he's lonely he
wants
friendship
okay so in other words the Bible is
fundamentally A Story of Friendship of
two poets who are alone in the world and
who found friendship and comfort in the
existence in each
other okay and the way the Bible
accomplishes is through the idea of
Covenant so in their Bible there are
four covenants promises so the first
Covenant um is between Noah and Yahweh
it's what we called a Noah had Covenant
the Noah Covenant the idea of this is
this after Yahweh destroys the world he
feels tremendous remorse for what he's
done he promises Noah as long as humans
are not too evil I will not destroy the
world okay if humans stay good I will
not destroy the world the second
Covenant is between Abraham and Yahweh
it's called The abrahamic Covenant and
in this Covenant Yahweh says to Abraham
if you and your ancestors sorry if you
and your descendants stay true to me I
will create a great nation out of you I
will give you the nation of
Israel the third Covenant is between
Moses and Yahweh it's called The mosc
Covenant and the idea is if the
Israelites
follow the ten
commandments and worship Yahweh only
yahwe then Yahweh will protect them as a
nation Yahweh will show them favor okay
so so those are the three covenants but
when we went get to David called The
davidic Covenant something interesting
happens all three previously are what we
call conditional covenants if you do
this then I will do this but when we get
to David it's
unconditional I Yahweh will promise that
you David and your descendants will
forever
rule
Israel the House of David will forever
rule Israel okay it's an unconditional
Covenant that shows his Everlasting
friendship with David in other words the
divinite Covenant marks the end of
Biblical history Yahweh this great God
poet God who's been who searched a
universe for
friendship has now found his great
friend in David
and so his search has ended and Biblical
history has
ended
okay so this is a radical new idea in
human history how a king and a God can
be poets and how the world how reality
reality can be constructed through words
okay and that's why in the Bible there's
a very famous phrase called in the
beginning there was the word and that's
why um Jewish people are so literary
okay because that's part of the
tradition if you look at some of the
most famous writers the most some of the
most famous thinkers in the world um
they're mainly Jewish and again a lot of
it is because um the Jewish faith is a
first Faith to focus on literary
creation so that's the idea of
legitimacy cohesion all cohesion okay
the second purpose is create cohesion
and as we discussed after the Bron age
collapsed the land of canine was in
complete chaos you had all these Des you
had all these different groups within
canine you had uh the nomads from the
desert okay the the the bans you have
the Hill People of canine you have um
refugees from the cities of canine whove
been and these cities have been
destroyed you have Egyptian priests you
have four
mercenaries and now you have sea peoples
the these Greeks and these other peoples
who are coming into canine because
they've lost their lands um back at home
okay so you've got this very different
group of people together they're in
competition with other groups like the
Philistines so now they need to create a
national identity out of all this right
and that's what the Bible is doing guys
okay remember there's a concept we
learned that's very important in class
called synchonization right right
stiz it means when you bring different
religions together and create a new
religion so for example let's say my God
is Zeus and your God is Hera and I
conquer uh you and I make you part of my
people okay so what we do in this
instance is we marry our Gods to each
other
so now Zeus is married to Hera and they
have children like Aphrodite and Athena
okay and this is a way to soo the
process of Conquest because even though
I've conquered you I still have to live
with you
okay so we have to blend in our
different cultures this is also true for
the idea of genealogy family history
every tribe has a
patriarch okay and the reason why that
patriarch is to to tell the people we've
been in this land for the longest time
and that's why we have legitimacy and
control over this land because we were
here first okay now when tribes get
together they into marry they form
alliances what they do that's very
common is their ancestors merge together
and they become sons and fathers of each
other so as though it's like one family
history okay you take these different
family history and you merge them into
one line the same process of
synchonization okay so if you look at
this instance Abraham Isaac and Jacob
it's basically three major tribes of
Israel coming together to form one
family history in this instance the most
powerful family is that of Jacob because
Jacob Israel gives his name to the new
nation of Israel the second most
important person or tribe is Abraham
because he's the progenitor of this
family okay and third will be Isaac and
in fact in the Bible Isaac receives the
the least amount of
attention
Okay but the synchronization process
also helps us
explain
Moses because we've been looking for
hundred years and we have not found any
evidence that MO Moes ever existed or
anyone like Moses existed
in Egypt okay so what's Moses doing well
what Moses is doing is explaining why
there are Egyptian
priests in the nation of Israel right
and why are priests important because if
you're David and you're now King you
want to create legitimacy and you want
to create Authority and the best way you
create Authority is by centralizing your
power back then the best and easiest way
to centralize power is by
centralizing religious ritual does that
make sense so what he did was this he
created he made this new capital
Jerusalem and he built something called
the Temple of Jerusalem which became the
house of Yahweh this is where Yahweh
lived so if you wanted to worship Yahweh
and you had to because he your God you
have to come all the way to Jerusalem to
offer a sacrifice and who controlled the
sacrifice process
priests
okay and why did the priest sacri and
why did the priest Egyptian priests why
are they controlling the sacrifice
process because they're the ones Moses
who led the people of Israel out of
Egypt the ones who
delivered the the Israelites into
Freedom Moses is an Egyptian name it
means son of
okay so it's a very common Egyptian name
so for example Ramses means son of Rah
okay so ramse is a is a very famous
Egyptian Pharaoh Ramses means son of Rah
the son
God so both Moses and his brother Aaron
these are Egyptian names for Egyptian
priests okay so David was heavily
reliant on these Egyptian priests in
order to centralize
Authority also the idea of circumcision
it is an ancient Egyptian practice that
PRI specialized in right so if the new
law is to be a member of Israel to be an
Israelite means you have to get
circumcised you have to circumcise your
children you're going to go to an
Egyptian priest to circumcise your
children because they're good at that
and they know how to do that okay does
that make sense so by making
circumcision the major Mark of what it
means to be an Israelite it gives
Authority and power to these Egyptian
priests okay does that make sense okay
um the judges what we believe is the
judges are these Local Heroes that bring
in all the other tribes of Israel
together okay so in other words if you
are a member of this new nation of
Israel you have a diety or an ancestor
within the cosmology of the
Bible okay and that's this explains why
the history of Israel is so con
convoluted contradictory and complex
because it's trying to create a national
identity where everyone all tribes all
everyone is able to contribute
effectively to the creation of the
nation of
Israel okay any questions before I
continue is this clear to you guys
what's what's going
on any other
questions all right now the last
question is differentiation and this is
the most important okay because remember
you have Egyptian priest in Israel how
do we know they're loyal to Israel and
not to Egypt because the Egyptian priest
went to war with a
pharaoh we have Canaanites within the
state of Israel how do we know they're
loyal because they went to war with the
Canaanites okay so in the Bible what's
interesting read the Bible is the
Israelites in in their history went to
war with everyone okay the Egyptians the
Philistines the Canaanites went to war
with everyone why because they had
members from every
single geography and location in that
area and so they need to differentiate
themselves the best way you
differentiate yourself is by going to
war with them does that make
sense oh also like also guys um when I
use the word
Nation um I have to warn you this is not
the modern sense okay Nation it's a
loose political affiliation that is
fluid today the nation state uh you're
Chinese you're stuck being Chinese okay
but back then if you're an Israelite
guess what you could walk across the
street and become a moabit okay so the
IDE the idea of identity back was
extremely loose and fluid so when we use
the term mulite or canite basically
we're talking talking about a geographic
location that has some political
force but it's not a fixed identity okay
the very idea of ethnicity
race group identity back then was
extremely fluid was basically
non-existent okay so Israel the very
idea of Israel it's a literary creation
the idea of Israelite it is a political
creation all right doesn't make sense
guys any questions so far before I move
on
okay are you
clear okay all right
all right so this explains why the Bible
is structured the way it is okay but
then the question then is and this is a
very important question is okay you know
what this was standard cultural practice
back then everyone did this to create uh
identity so why is it we have a Bible
today and not say other text from Egypt
or
Mesopotamia why is it that the Bible was
able to conquer the world basically
right because you have two billion
Christians you have a billion um Muslims
the Bible was able to conquer the world
and capture the imagination of
humanity and here I want to explain why
the Bible is so
powerful it was how it was written that
made it so
powerful okay so last class we talked
about the ology of David about the BBA
story about the Abner story and we
believe the person who wrote those
stories are what we call the court
historian we have absolutely no idea who
he is he's basically the official
historian of the court of David okay and
every Court will have an official
historian and those stories are good but
they're not they're not literary okay
they're just propaganda and spin
but the person who wrote the Bible
especially Genesis was a unique literary
genius of the Statue of Homer and Plato
and Dante okay the person who wrote the
Bible who first wrote the Bible was an
incredible literary genius and we call
her the
yahwist okay why do we call the her the
yahs it's just convention because
because she
uses
um Yahweh as the name of God and other
writers don't actually use Yahweh as the
name of God okay so so by convention we
call her the Yahweh now the question
then is who is
she and we're fairly certain she's a
well it's a she okay and as I show you
we're fairly certain it's a she because
she focuses not on
war not on
conflict but on domestic tragedy and
Affairs child birth marriage love and
this is unique in human history okay so
we're fairly confident it's a
she there are many who believe she is of
the court of David the reason why is uh
first of all um what she writes is very
favorable to the court of
David also back then as you can imagine
in um only arist aristocratic woman had
the privilege of reading and writing
okay she clearly had access to uh the
mythology of Egypt Mesopotamia Anatolia
she has access to a great
education uh so we believe she's a
princess I will go further and make the
argument that she must be either the
daughter or the granddaughter of the
king of King David okay I would I would
I would make this argument that she has
has to be the daughter or the
granddaughter of King David and the
reason why is what she wrote and I I'll
show you what she wrote what she wrote
was so controversial and so unique and
so imaginative that the
priesthood could not possibly accept
what she did if she was just if she was
just a priest or she if she was just an
aristocratic of low birth there there
was no
way her writings would become
um part of the Bible okay so she must
have been someone of high Authority and
there is actually a president for this
so so for example we know that in about
2000 BC this this is a you know at least
a thousand years before the Yahweh began
to write the Sargon of aad who is the
first great Empire Builder okay the
first emperor basically and this is
someone that back then during the time
of King David ever knew and worshiped
okay King David knew about him and he
knew about his
practices when King s of adad conquered
Mesopotamia he appointed his daughter
name um and
her
du to be like The High Priestess of
their religion but what's interesting
about her is she's a poet and she is the
first name author in human history okay
okay this is 2000 BC she wrote a lot of
poetry so there is a history a president
for these Kings to appoint their
daughters to be the official poet of
their Nation okay so that's why I think
the jaw is the Yahweh is but honestly
we'll never know and it's not important
okay we we just have to know she was an
exceptional literary
genius who made the Bible what it is
today all right so let's go over some of
her literary contributions very
shortly and again because the Bible has
been reducted for about 2,000 years
3,000 years we've lost a lot of her
original writings okay so I will I we we
analyze a couple of stories that we know
for sure she wrote the first is called
Adam and Eve the second is the story of
Jacob and Rachel okay all right so you
think you know the story of Adam and Eve
but I guarantee you it's wrong okay I
guarantee you even you know the story of
Adam and Eve it's
wrong all right so let's go over the
official or the mainstream understanding
of the story of Adam and
Eve God told Adam and Eve listen this is
the Garden of Eden it's Paradise you can
do whatever you want you life is easy
apples fall from the sky okay you can
pick tomatoes and carrots from the
ground life is easy it's Paradise for
you but there's one rule and only one
rule in the Garden of Eden the rule is
do not eat
from the Tree of knowledge of Good and
Evil because it's
poison and of course Adam and Eve had to
disobey God and God became so angry that
he
banished Adam and Eve from the Garden of
Eden and that was the our Act of
Disobedience the First Act of
Disobedience our first sin the original
sin that um has doomed us forever until
the Redemption of Jesus right that's a
story we all
know the story is completely and utterly
wrong that's not what it says in the
Bible okay so I'll explain first what
the what the Bible says and then I'll
explain how we can interpret with the
story okay so God says to Adam and Eve
don't eat that fruit
okay and then Adam and Eve are curious
why can't you eat that fruit and then
Eve meets a serpent on the ground and
Eve and the serpent
talk and Eve says basically says we
can't eat that fruit and the serpent
says
why Eve says it's
poisonous so says no it's not poisonous
you're being lied
to the reason why Yahweh does not want
you eat from the fruit is once you eat
it you'll become like God your eyes will
open you have the knowledge of Good and
Evil and then Eve gets angry because she
feels manipulated and she convinces Adam
to eat the fruit as well so the the
fruit and their eyes are open now they
have not of Good and Evil Yahweh visits
them in the garden and he discovers
they're hiding from him
and Yahweh commands them to come out and
he sees right away they're embarrassed
about their nakedness they're
embarrassed about being confronted by
Yahweh so Yahweh knows they've eaten the
fruit Adam says to Yahweh it's Eve's
fault Eve says to Yahweh it's the
Serpent's fault and Yahweh decides to
punish all three he says to the
serpent from now on you will Slither on
the ground and you'll be hunted by
men Eve from now on you and all your
descendants will suffer the Pains of
childbirth child birth will be an
extremely painful process and then he
says to Adam from now on on you must
sweat to grow food to feed yourself from
now on life will be hardship it will be
a a it will be toil and pain and
suffering okay and then he does this
okay this is very interesting and this
is where the
Bible demonstrates its genius okay and
the Lord God made garments of skins for
the man and his wife and clothed them
then the Lord said see the man has
become like one of us knowing good and
evil and now he might reach out his hand
and take also from the Tree of Life and
live forever okay this is where the
Bible is genius because it's telling us
why God is banishing Adam and Eve from
the Garden of Eden it's telling us it's
because there's another tree God didn't
mention to them it's called The Tree of
Life
and it allows you to live
forever so why is this a problem well
there are two things that differentiate
God from us humans the first thing is
God has knowledge of Good and Evil
second thing is God lives forever that's
the that's
it okay that's the only difference so if
Adam and Eve now now know good and evil
if they eat from the Tree of Life they
can live forever so God's afraid will be
become like
God therefore to protect the tree of
life he has to banish us from the garden
okay
yeah excuse
me yeah exactly think okay okay what is
good and evil okay so this is what this
so this is a really comp complicate idea
okay but but good and evil does not mean
you know God and you know de you know
Satan that's that's not what it means it
means you know what's good for you and
what's bad for you so for example before
I knew good and
evil I hit this table okay I feel pain
right and I'm like what pain what is
that is that good or is that bad I don't
know so I do it again okay and I do it
again I cannot learn from my mistakes
because I cannot differentiate what's
good for me and what's bad for me
but now I know good and evil I'm like oh
I hit this thing it's I feel pain
therefore it's evil therefore I
shouldn't do it again therefore I should
avoid this table so knowing good and
evil means you have the capacity to
learn and to grow through a process of
self-reflection once you have judgment
once you're able to differentiate what's
good for you and what's bad for you you
can always grow as a person does that
make sense and if you can do this
forever the tree of life and live
forever it means you become God because
your knowledge is now
infinite okay does that make sense
that's what knowledge of Good and Evil
is the ability to differentiate for
yourself what is good for you and what
is bad for you to engage in a process of
reflection and self-growth
okay so God's
afraid that if we continue to grow we
will become as powerful
as God
himself any question any more questions
before I
continue okay the key line is this and
the Lord God made garments of skins for
the men his wife and clothed them this
this is right after he punishes Adam and
Eve this is right after he scolds
them
right this is God giving pitying them
and giving
them a
present this is very strange this is
paradoxical why would God do this okay
there are different ways to interpret
this but I think this is God showing
remorse and regret
okay this is a radical idea but this is
God saying to Adam and Eve I'm sorry for
this this is God showing remorse and
regret what is God showing remorse and
regret you show remorse and regret you
when you just say wrong right but what
did God do
wrong what did God do
wrong why why is God in the wrong
here it's a radical idea but can you
figure it
out okay God lied to Adam and Eve God
said to Adam and Eve do not eat from
this tree because it's
poisonous right so imagine this imagine
you're my two daughters okay and you're
like six or seven years old and you see
me at night drinking whiskey or beer I'm
really happy because I'm drinking
whiskey and beer so you two are curious
and you say to me dad what what is this
and I say it's um
poison and then you're like why are you
drinking poison dad like well because
because I'm older than you are when
you're as old as I am you can drink this
poison okay you two are now
curious right you're
curious why is dad drinking poison
so your uncle comes to the house one day
and you ask your uncle hey is alcohol
poisonous your uncle's like of course
it's not poisonous what are you talking
about and so of course what you two do
is you break into
the uh alcohol cabinet right and you
drink whiskey and you're very you become
very happy and you throw up I come home
and I shut at you you guys are terrible
I told you not to drink that go to your
room and you're suspend it for a month
okay you go to your room you cry and
then I come knocking and say hey uh do
you guys want to go out to McDonald's
and have a hamburger
together you do you understand the story
because I know I'm not wrong I should
have said to you alcohol is poisonous
okay I'm a bad parent so what's remark
about the story is it's
basically a
domestic
comedy you understand this is what
happens
among families all the time this is a
power of the story of Adam and Eve it's
a domestic comedy it's something we can
all relate to something we can all
understand what's also really powerful
about the story
is God is
fallible God is M has made a terrible
mistake what's important is this God
understands he's made a mistake that's
why he's showing remorse and
regret
okay so again Yahweh he's a poet God
he's curious about the world he wants to
have friends but he's
inexperienced he's naive he's a new
father so he's going to make
mistakes making mistakes is a
process of going up what makes humans
exceptional what makes humans unique
from animals is our capacity to make
mistakes and to learn from them because
we ate from the knowledge
of from the Tree of knowledge of Good
and
Evil
okay you see how radical all this is
these are radical new ideas in human
history God is
fible what's important is to understand
and admit your mistakes and grow from
them
okay
okay the story continues because now
Adam and Eve are banished from the
Garden of Eden they have two sons named
Cain and
Abel
Abel is a
Shepherd okay and Kane is a a farmer
both they both love God they both want
the respect the attention of
God so they present they they they give
presence to God um
Abel
um is a Shepherd so he offers mutton
okay to God and then Cain is a farmer so
he
offers I don't know like wheat or
vegetables to God God tastes both and
then God's like this
mutton it's tasty awesome thank you uh
Abel and then he eats Cain's offering
and kan's very anxious he's very excited
then Cain's like and Abel's like sorry
sorry and then God Yahweh is like this
fot sucks man all right and this is what
it says in the Bible and the Lord had
regard for Abel and his offering but for
Cain and his offering he had no
regard he hated Cain's present he loved
Abel's present so Cain was very angry
and his countenance fell the Lord said
to Cain why are you angry if you do well
will you not be
accepted
okay so again it's a domestic comedy
you're my girls you're my you're my
daughters you go to school and you work
very hard on presenting a present to me
right and I say to one of you oh this is
an awesome present thank you and I say
to the other you suck man okay I'm being
a bad parent God is being a terrible
parent
okay if you do well will you not be
accepted you suck man the problem isn't
me the problem is you you just
suck
okay and of course what happens next is
Cain kills abble but then what happens
next is interesting because Yahweh finds
out about this he
banishes Cain and then Cain says to God
hey if you banish me people will know I
committed wrong and therefore I will be
killed by other people then Yahweh says
to Cain okay I will put a mark
on you The Mark of
Cain and if anyone touches you then I
will punish that person I will protect
you with The Mark of Cain and this is
again God showing remorse and regret for
what he's done because God knows in his
heart he's not wrong
here but what allow God
to understand he committed wrong is
because Cain argued with
him okay Cain argued
back so this is a radical conception of
faith in the in the Hebrew
Bible
Faith love of God requires you to argue
with God because it's only through the
process of argument that God who's
fallible will learn and grow
so when you argue when you fight back
you're helping the other person
grow okay any questions about this story
before I move on as you're going to see
it's a powerful story that reveals so
much about the idea of faith and
Justice and Divinity okay and any more
questions before I move
on okay so again the yahs is a literary
genius and there are two things that
make her stand out that make that make
her unique in the history of literature
the first is her economy economy just
means using as few words as
possible
to express as much as possible okay you
can see the story of Adam and Eve the
story of canil it's very economical
she's using very few words but within
these words are a universe of
ideas almost infinite meaning you can
interpret these stories any way you want
okay the second idea is
irony irony just means she's
funny
okay if you tell your kids don't eat
that Apple don't eat that fruit because
it's poisonous guess what your kids are
going to eat that fruit okay and then
you're going to look like an idiot
because it's not
poisonous so it it's
ironic she's making fun of Yahweh she's
making fun of the highest Authority in
the Israelite
faith and again that's why if she were
not
the daughter of David or grand daughter
of David there's no way this story would
have gone into the Bible
okay but it's a great story that has
infinite literary
power does that make
sense the last story I will mention is a
story of um Rachel and Jacob it's a very
short story okay so what happens is
this jacob runs away from his brother
Asa because Jacob stole asa's Birthright
and
blessing and Jacob ends up with relative
named
leban and leban has two daughters Leah
and Rachel uh Leah is the eldest Rachel
is the younger
one and Jacob falls in love with Rachel
right away and he says to
Lebon I will work for you for free for
seven years and then I will want your
daughter Rachel's
hand uh in return for my for my work
lean says well you're a relative and
it's better for me to give her to you
than to complete stranger so yeah okay
seven years
pass and there's a wedding between
Rachel and
Jacob that
night Jacob has sex with a woman he
wakes up and sees it's not Rachel it's
Leah he slept with Leah he is now
married to Leah then Jacob says to Laban
you've tricked me and then Laban says it
is the custom of our people to marry the
firstborn first we have to marry Leah
off first before we can marry off Rachel
if you continue to work for me for seven
years I will give you Rachel as well and
Jacob
agrees okay so it's a very short
story and there's a lot of economy and
irony in the
story but again within the short story
there's a universe of ideas and emotions
if you're able to think very clearly and
closely about the story we will
discover that
a Rachel and Leah hate each other how do
we know that because Leah
stole Jacob from Rachel we can
[Applause]
imagine that when Leon announced that
Rachel would marry Jacob Leah was very
jealous and for seven years every night
at dinner Leah would cry and scream at
her
father how could you embarrass me like
this I'm your first point do I needan
nothing to you we can imagine the family
drama and the comedy right is like you
know what if after seven years Jacob
Mar's Rachel they're going to run off
together right and for the rest of my
life I'm stuck with Leah screaming at me
and hitting me in the
head
for the rest of my life right so he's
like I need to figure out how to get out
of this deal right so that's why he
tricks
Jacob we can also figure out that Rachel
and Jacob love each other their love is
the greatest love in the world because
first of all Jacob's willing to put up
with this crap for another seven years
in order to be with Rachel right second
of all Rachel is willing to wait for
Jacob she could at any time just run off
and be with someone else but she's
willing to endure she's willing to
suffer okay so we
imagine the entire family Dynamic and
history based on just a few sentences in
the Bible that's that's the power of the
Yahweh the power the Yahweh she's really
writing about what it means to be human
what it means to have a family and
that's why the Bible endures to this day
because there are these powerful stories
in the
Bible that tell us that reveal to us
what it means to be human what it means
to love what it means to forgive what it
means to have
family and that's why the Bible has
inspired people for thousands of
years because in these stories you are
part of the writing process it's
co-creation okay your meaning
co-creation your meaning your
understanding your interpretation is
what gives
life to these words they that many words
but your understanding of these words is
what makes these words powerful to
you and again these stories are unique
in human history the story of Adam and
Eve is everyone knows the story of Adam
and
Eve okay because it's just a powerful
story you can also argue
the power of Adam and
Eve is
because it makes us nostalgic for the
ice age right remember the Ice Age were
we were in egalitarian society where
everyone was
equal and the garden of Edom is a
metaphor a symbol for that time okay so
it is provoking or activating our
Nostalgia for that time within each of
us must be that a long lost memory of a
time when we humans were alone in the
world there wer that many of us but
life was fairly Pleasant okay food was
plentiful we were all friends with with
each
other we didn't really struggle against
each other we really didn't struggle
against nature we were one with nature
and and with each
other okay
any any
questions so who do the Christians
believe to have written the Bible okay
who do the Christians believe to have
written the Bible well God right this is
the exact these are the words of
God and so in uh the Bible um there are
people called
prophets
prophets and
how prophets work is they visit heaven
or they visit by an Angel and there's
one scene where the angel or God takes a
parchment and puts it into the mouth of
the Prophet so the prophets is speaking
every
word that's a direct word of God does
that make
sense like it it's it's almost
like he's
just a male man I'm God I put a
parchment in your mouth you come back to
earth and you
basically uh announce the word of God
okay so there are people who
believe God wrote Every Word okay but
this is only minority of Christians most
Christians believe that whoever wrote
the Bible was inspired by
God that these are um prophets who were
inspired by God to write down the truths
of God
but if you actually try to read the
Bible by yourself it's impossible okay
because it's been redacted so many times
as I explained to you last class there
are at least four different sources in
the Bible that have been splashed
together randomly and it's been edited
constantly um over the
centuries okay but honestly no one reads
the Bible in its
entirety what usually happens is people
only read sections of the
Bible most people get
their get understanding from the Bible
from preachers okay and preachers will
explain to you what these stories mean
but you won't actually have to read them
together does that make sense so what
I'm offering you today is not a
scriptural interpretation of the Bible
I'm offering you a uh what we call a
literary interpretation of the Bible
okay uh any more
questions are you guys clear about
this okay so um we'll continue this the
Bible next class and next class we will
look at the religion of zor
aism because when the Persian Empire
conqu the world World Zionism their
religion will start to merge with the
Bible which creates new ideas okay that
will eventually become the basis of
Christianity okay